salut à tous c'est le début de la saison
4 d'envergure
on va vous présenter aujourd'hui les
pros semelle et prospects mais plus
intéressant c'est que les prospects les
plus intéressants et je vous prête pas
vous moquez droit de 7,7 privé pour la
draft 2021
on les a pas encore beaucoup vu jouer
mais on a fait appel aux aux druides
antoine dérangé qui est de retour pour
nous parler de des procès les plus
intéressants de cette cuvée ben
évidemment s'est également renseigné et
puis on à romain est là à la fois pour
se moquer de mes difficultés d'élocution
toujours sont notamment bien de toi tu
es si vous écoutez les saisons
précédentes c'est pas grave hein c'est
pas ton métier non bah non pas comme si
j'étais professionnel et et romain qui
va pouvoir nous parler des prospects
français qu'on attend pour cette draft
2021 alors ça sera sans doute moins que
pour la draft 2020 néanmoins on a des
chances voire un ou plusieurs français
drafté on en parlera pour le moment
générique saison 4 épisode 1 c'est parti
[Musique]
alors là on commence par le favori pour
le numéro sava messieurs je vous ai même
pas accueilli cette saison 4 oui tous
peut être tous perçu une catastrophe les
bonnes manières ma bonne dame
ça va bien depuis deux saisons mais on
accueille on retrouve antoine quand même
ben tu es tu es content tu vas rien oui
absolument je m'ennuyais de sa douce
voix de sorcy antoine qui a bien voulu
venir dépanner puisque ce sera désormais
le dépanneur dépanneur tout ce qu'ils
sont voilà j'ai ça et puis comme il ya
plein de gens que que j'ai pu voir de
les étés passés qu'on n'a pas encore
trop vu exactement
tu les as vus pour contextualiser pour
ceux qui découvrent peut-être le podcast
à dans un championnat fiba le stelle u17
alors il y en a certains que j'ai
découvert au 19 lloyd et dernier et en a
d'autres comme jane green que j'ai pu
voir il ya deux ans trois ans je sais qu
en 2007 america croyants non en 18
america peut-être avant je sais plus ça
fait en tant que langue des championnats
fiba d'été qui nous permettent de
commencer à connaître les prospects
avant qu'ils arrivent en nba puisque
prouver des matchs de high school heures
en france deux lycées ont peu compliqué
on commence par le favori donc là on va
vous présenter vraiment des favoris pour
aller les gens qui vont se battre pour
le first pick pour le podium de la
prochaine draft
en tout cas comme on le voit aujourd'hui
évidemment ça peut changer pendant la
saison on l'a vu pour 2020 mais le
favori offer spx et caïds cadets tuning
gamme que peux-tu nous dire de son
profil antoine en quelques mots on l'a
vu il joue à oklahoma state 2 m 01 et il
joue plutôt avec le ballon avec ouais il
joue meneur de mètres 0-1 d'affaires de
mettre 10 d'envergure le gamin est
athlétique
[Musique]
il joue meneur et ils jouent de façon
assez légitime comme un meneur après
c'est pas un meneur gestionnaire
on va dire c'est plus un meneur à la
halle à lebron james en initiateur
initiateurs qui va créer des décalages
pour lui-même et qui ce faisant on va
réussir à mettre ses coéquipiers en
bonne position quoi ces îles sont basket
après sa passe est pas non plus un génie
de la maine quoi mais on pourrait dire
en quelque sorte que c'est une sorte de
bên simons plus plus quoi ben simons qui
s'échouent tu es qui s'échouent tort
mieux la gérer au mieux les bensimon
j'étais pas du tout en amour avec son
shoot l'été dernier je trouvais que même
quand il drivait en fait il avait des
problèmes définition ce qui m'a
fortement inquiété et là sur les matchs
sur le match que j'ai vu il le toucher
était plutôt bon mais je les trouvais
donc
donc voilà c'est un grand meneur
athlétique c'est ce qu'on va observer
cette année en gros si on devait définir
les enjeux de l'année pour que nine
gamme c'est est ce qu'il va pouvoir
shooter et ce qui va pouvoir créer avec
régularité dans une équipe qui est pas
pétri de talent il dit il ya vraiment du
talent et des joueurs à suivre dans le
pivot canadien monde crie à la télé ou
qui que j'ai pu quand il disait
américain bref il ya un ou deux tweeters
commencé c'est pas si franchement c'est
pas dégueulasse en fait pas de nom mais
c'est pas dégueulasse mais je veux dire
c'est pas c'est pas gonzaga on parle à
86 sur eux il n'y a pas autant de qi
basket
voilà donc les enjeux de l'année pour
cuningham je passe à ben un autre
notre favori pour le top 3 de cette
draft
on va parler de johnatan coming à huy
qui va jouer en j league cette année
alors comment va se dérouler la g-league
ça pour le moment je n'ai pas non plus
cherché mais je crois qu'il ya des
incertitudes
je crois que c'est une erreur de la
savoie mais c'est ça donc c'est un bon
c'est ça pour qu'on fasse le choix donc
il n'est pas tout seul dans cette équipe
de jilib on parlera john green un peu
plus tard mais lui johnattan kumming à
c'est un peu le même profil que
cunningham peut-être moins explosif plus
puissant et un peu voyez un peu plus
lourd sur posture paraît un peu loin de
ce que j'ai de ce que j'ai ici c'est
maturation physique que vaslui d'un site
à l'autre mais j'ai eu beaucoup de sept
qui sont assez suit donc de mettre trois
cinémas bulls est de 1210 c200 réunit
donc c'est un gros bébé c'est un gars
qui a un corps qui est déjà prêt pour la
nba
je dirai pas qui joue pareil comme
quelques années gamme c'est beaucoup
plus un joueur de voler dans l'espace
avec son avec son physique il pas réputé
pour être un grand passeur comme janet
gamme mais c'est vraiment un joueur qui
toute sa vie est un peu un homme parmi
les enfants qui est demandé une qui
réussit à 7 ce qui m'en a dominé un peu
tout le monde
ce que j'ai remarqué en faisant un peu
de recherche au juge ce matin sic
angelides sigillée il y a ils ont bien
entouré des jeunes
il va y avoir des vétérans dans l'équipe
comme bobby brown qui avait joué avec
houston et les creepers et amir johnson
brandon ashley si vous vous rappelez
luis arizona donc
donc ça c'est intéressant de voir un
joueur comme ça qui est prêt qui très
brute quelques heures un athlète à
l'état
qui peut être pas justement l'athlète le
plus vertical au monde et le plus
explosif que latéralement de le voir
développer des outils de le voir devons
développer des outils points qui vont
qui vont lui donner une espèce de cartes
de visite en baisse de longévité
parce que pour l'instant six jeunes
attendent comme un gars n'est pas
capable de dominer physiquement et de
jouer un beau livre à la calomnie
ce qui est clairement son son mode
d'emploi qui est clairement son modèle
j'ai des doutes
à savoir s'ils vont être joie aussi
dominants on aime bien ce soir pour
l'instant on voit beaucoup d'oeufs de
poule hoc même trop de pollock à trois
points des pôles up sur le bescherelle
beaucoup de d'initiation à l'ied de jibe
step donc ses fonctione pour l'instant
mais je sais pas si ils développent
aussi développer des outils plus plus
plus plus fin et plus sophistiquées je
sais pas à quel point on pourra qu une
force dominante en billets ça va être
l'enjeu de cette année c'est un seul au
moment de 20 au moment où on parle
et de toute façon au moment de la draft
aussi ce sera un des joueurs les plus
jeunes puisque comme disait une
chanteuse vient d'avoir 18 ans s'est
laissé l'instant dalida de gens
profitent pour rebondir sur une perche
absolument royal deux choses sur commune
galles la première c'est qu'il a il ya
des genoux en verre il ya un prêtre fac
sur ce truc là ce qui explique aussi un
petit peu le l'explosivité tout relatif
du bonheur
la deuxième c'est que quand le on va
dire le je cherchais je cherchais un
qualificatif qui qu'ils soient à la fois
neutre mais marquant quand un petit peu
le
le plus simple le canadien qui est à
monaco a débarqué à antibes l'an dernier
là il avait comme projet amis c'est vrai
oui il avait comme projet de me ramener
comme il ya dans l'effectif pour le
faire jouer en pro b cette année alors
réelle ambition délire nous ne savons
pas les enquêteurs n'ont pas pu
déterminer le truc mais apparemment il y
avait quand même une volonté en tout cas
de l'entourage du joueur et des agences
j'avais bien compris à l'époque de de
tâter quand même la piste internationale
à l'instar de ce qui s'était fait à la
bombe
cela l'a récupéré en titre bien sûr je
pense qu'il y avait un delta mais mais
en tout cas il était il était sur le
marché sur le marché international pour
pour dire prendre un petit peu la
température
ouais et du coup il y 30 j league si j
league il ya puisque dans cette équipe
il y aura notamment avec lui à zahia
todd des chaînes x
donc on parlera pas de ces deux joueurs
ce soir qui sont dus un petit peu plus
bas et il y aura aussi des jalles and
green antoine qui est un arrière on va
dire explosif
c'est peu de le dire ouais ouais ouais
j'ai des migraines c'est assez cool
c'est j'aime bien regarder jouer post 2
il doit faire un peu moins un mètre 96
96 voilà c'est pas mal scoreur scoreur
pur très très fléchit très athlétique
c'est plus athlétique que cadet que
d'une gamme clairement tout en plus faim
tout temps tout en explosivité quoi mon
explosivité verticale voilà c'est j'ai
passé un athlétisme soft on va dire mais
mais j'aime bien ça va beaucoup ça va
beaucoup attaquer le cercle ça a pas
peur du tout jamais rien parce que pour
les joueurs fin comme ça parfois au
contact des patrouilles allait lui n'y
va qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire après problème c'est que c'est un
pur produit du circuit
du circuit américain du circuit ou et
compagnie il joue pour lui c'est un
joueur de saint jour de plus grande
qu'un mais c'est ce que c'est c'est
pouvoir garder alors après pour de ce
point de vue là la g-league peut
peut-être lui lui convenir puisque on
sait que c'est pas le championnat réputé
pour être le plus dur le plus serré où
les défenses ont dû s'y joue c'est un
puissant méta se développe
ceci dit la d-league est de plus en plus
sérieuse c'est parce que c'était ya 5-6
le projet le projet global on voit j'en
avais parlé
j'avais évoqué le très vite fait avec
rémy la cote cogiter sur bide
le projet je trouve est très intéressant
de la part de la nba
parce que ça va permettre peut-être deux
on va dire de limiter un petit peu le
certaines dérives sur certains prospects
en les encadrant tout de suite si le
truc se faire réellement à savoir
l'encadrement le développement et la
possibilité d'avoir l'équivalent d'une
dune scholarship en fait d'une bourse
pour étudier à côté existe et se met en
place de manière efficace il ya vraiment
un
je trouve un créneau à prendre pour la
nba un vrai coup d'arrêt aussi sur
certains vont dire sur certains
certaines pratiques au niveau les
initiés sac de sport et autres
gourmandises dans le coffre est
effectivement une capacité d'encadrer
les gamins qui peut être qui peut être
intéressante c'est quelque chose si
quelque chose à surveiller parce que
finalement on se rend compte que c'est
un modèle qui se fait dans qu'il existe
maintenant dans pas mal de ligue et
championnat où au final on regroupe des
gamins pour les faire jouer pour le
développer c'est toujours toujours très
interviews qu'ils étaient lourds ce sac
adidas dans le coffre de la kangoo bleu
garée sur le parking
ce cher bill a eu énormément de mal à le
descendre à la demande est des gros bras
de le faire
nous n'avons rien dit de ce d'ailleurs
toute ressemblance avec des personnes
réelles est totalement faux bien sûr
désigne parenthèses si vous cherchez à
vous loger dans la région de memphis
dans le tennessee
je connais des bébés nageurs et
déménageur il peut avoir des déménageurs
également une aide au logement
contacté même si c'est quelque chose si
vous êtes sur la route de memphis
chômage rip pour finir sur des allen
green antoine qu'est ce que tu attends
tu de lui cette année
on réfléchit à comment on va observer
les matchs de djelic parce qu'on a déjà
beaucoup de matches à regarder rainsy
déballer mais qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
que à quoi les scouts devons être
attentifs pour savoir s'il sera plutôt
top 3 ou plutôt et seulement s'il veut
confirmer il faut continuer à montrer
les mêmes dispositions athlétique et
c'est pour moi il est
j'ai vraiment mon top 3 g trois joueurs
que j'aime particulièrement dans cette
classe ils essaient vraiment la
troisième roue du carrosse quoi s'il
veut vraiment progresser il a intérêt à
[Musique]
apprendre à jouer au basket
collectivement polonais pour la whey
c'est ça pour l'instant c'est il peut
faire gagner son équipe de pl est grande
mais faut qu'ils puissent faire gagner
une équipe de basket c'est pas la même
chose et il a tous les outils pour
réussir alors je sais juste mentionné
cas je ne veux pas être en ciel
pessimiste a bien sûr mais quand on
commence on a joué au basket à un
athlète à il ya 20 ans comme ça c'est 19
20 ans c'est quand même n'est pas le
moins du sacerdoce et après c'est
peut-être un peu exagéré de dire que
c'est pas du tout joué au basket en mai
dans le conte dans un contexte 55
organisé c'est compliqué après c'est un
joueur qui sur du jeu et sur du jeu
assez ouvert sur du jeu tout terrain de
la cour des choses comme ça partir moins
les la ligne droite c'est très compliqué
de de stopper ces mecs là mais quand ça
va devoir jouer demi terrain un petit
peu plus sous contrôle
il ya chantier est un chantier énorme il
ya un nom qui montrent de plus en plus
comme candidats au top 3 de la draft
2021 peut-être kentucky brandon boston
junior ou jay boston s'est toujours pas
comment il faut dire ben d'entre nous ce
joueur que le béotien devant et il
n'aura pas tort d'ailleurs devant son
écran comparé à un brandon ingram du
fait de la longueur et de la finesse des
eaux
on va dire mais mais c'est pas tout à
fait le même joueur mais c'est le même
possible ouais le nom et les cheveux
aussi je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
références assez facile pour le
rattraper un brigand je trouve que côté
je ne sais pas du tout le même jour je
pense que des trois joueurs dont je veux
parler aujourd'hui celui qui a le jeu
technique que plus avancé john senden
wilders le pied le shoot ou si la
finition
j'étais quand même impressionné par ben
laden personnes malgré qu'ils piquent
grosses lacunes
c'est un poste 2 à 2 016 je ne m'abuse
oui toutes nos maisons en bois il est
entre eux il ya un peu sur le côté mais
dirige en effet à j 6 185 livres mais
quand même assez sûr de nous contacter
le fini conduites humaines au contact
plus qu'une fois un scoreur peu qui peut
créer pour lui-même qui est fait bah je
pense que le highlight de lui qui se
tape un step back dans le visage de sa
couverture a fait le tour d'internet
maintenant c'est un ajustement qui
peuvent scorer pu créer pour lui même
qui peut shooter qui peut finir au ciel
de différentes façons le vus face des
opérateurs
les banques ce qu'ils arrivent à faire
tête genoux tête avant de tirer avec le
ballon je sais pas non à la question
kurde patinage là oui tu fais ballon sur
la tête banon sur joue au ballon c'est
peut-être comme quoi tu fais d or ce
très dur à réaliser ça mais surprise
c'est exact ans d'arrêt sélection
française
non je suis une connerie mais maintenant
ça justement j'étais très impressionnée
choses étranges dans ses deux premiers
matches il était 0 en certes de 3 points
mais personnellement je vois rien de
mauvais à sortir il ya une bonne
élévation son sort au lycée vraiment
très haut
je pense que c'est juste qu'ils étaient
vraiment très très précis dans son jeu
dans cette banque dans ses deux premiers
matches donc je crois que les tirs à
trois points vont finir par rentrer mais
si on enlève les tirs à trois points son
niveau d'efficacité offensivement est
absolument incroyable premier match sans
escales trois points il réussit à 70%
il a fait 70 pour ça ou manier donc ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose
le problème avec brandon bass tonnes
c'est que il défend pas il défend pas du
tout il est perdu en défense j'ai mis un
clip sur sur twitter si vous voulez
aller voir les délits perdu en défense
et ils passent pas par dessus les
passeports par dessus les écrans géants
vont peut-être s'améliorer avec un peu
plus de cohésion avec ses coéquipiers
mais il s'est fait passer en bacs screen
c'était il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
croûtes à manger de ce côté là il est
très lent que ça va le sauver
de plus sur plusieurs jeux mais il ya
beaucoup de croûtes à manger
côté défense bon c'est c'est ce qu'on va
observer principalement et puis aussi sa
capacité à à créer pour les autres aussi
ce temps est assez peu développée
évidemment il aura des difficultés comme
il y avait une action quand le chumby
morts
qui ment pas remarqué de ce côté-là côté
création pour les autres il a faim trois
points il a complètement raté il allait
chercher le morvan il a passé à son
coéquipier pour deux points faciles dont
j'ai l'impression qu'il est au moins
qu'il ya engagé de ce côté là la lumière
au bout du tunnel pour m
oui message c'est peut-être aussi qu'il
arrive à calais oulala en glissant
antoine y est le genre williams zaïre
william ça s'écrit z et à y ait eu des
beaucoup de mal à le prononcer il joue à
stanford qu'on a beaucoup regardé la
saison passée avec tyler perry et il va
jouer avec oscar da silva avec spencer
jones dans une équipe très sexy qui est
il
williams alors quand j'étais en train de
manger en même temps mort et peut alors
c'est pas celui que j'ai le plus vu on
l'a on l'a assez peu vu au final mais
c'est clair que tout de suite il a
intrigué parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
est qui visiblement long qui joue avec
qui je serai poste 3-4 ans avec team usa
qui est très long et l'impression de
longueur était renforcée par le fait qu'
il est encore jeune pas trop des pôles
un peu de coups et puis et puis une
espèce d'afro absent que c'était une
tige le machin quoi et en fait c'est une
tige qui est très très de cette éthique
qui très très explosif qui va kiki qui
monte très vite et au début bon j'étais
là bon c'est juste un athlète qui est
sain c'est un petit jeune américain et c
est en fait il a un peu plus que ça il a
été mal utilisée par team us f1 comme
souvent défensivement il a été mal
utilisé et offensivement il n'a pas eu
grand grand grande opportunité on va
dire il était plus 9e 10e
mais il a aussi à faire quelques trucs
j'avais des doutes sur son intellect
personnellement séparés sur sa
compréhension sur sa destinée à
standford c'est qu'il est lui pas bête
normalement et voilà et cogeco j'ai su
qu'il est est une ford gt un peu étonné
parce que sur le terrain il des fois ils
paraissent un peu perdu pas comme quoi
il ya du voilà il ya du g10 à cannes un
cerveau derrière et on nage en avait eu
adam cohen l'assistant coach de
standford l'année dernière dans le
podcast vous pouvez le retrouver sur
notre site
adam quinn qui nous disait que williams
allait jouer une bonne partie des
possessions en tant que porteur de
ballon tant qu'initiateur de pick and
roll donc ça va être intéressant
après ce qu'il faut voir donc pour ce
jour c'est comment il va être utilisée
de mes souvenirs il est utilisé vraiment
en poste 4 5
non ça sera plus qu'un anti bio et c'est
alors qu'il passait derrière original
perry qui fait 250 kg élevé lui lui
lance des 40 était vraiment hors de
position avec team usa côté claire mines
est possible parce que evans mobley
étaient baissées donc fallait voilà
fallait utiliser différemment mais
j'aimerais j'ai vraiment envie d'en voir
plus quoi bon avoir mais un tueur un
intrigant et williams du côté de
standford qui n'a pas encore joué cette
saison on enregistre lui lundi soir
peut-être qu'il aura joué d'ici la
sortie du podcast ben tonton troisième
joueur à présenter c'est un joueur qui
joue à diou qui s'appelle jaden encore
une fois c'est l'année des jo l'aisne
on est sur le deuxième il nous en reste
un challenge en sonne plutôt poste 4
j'ai pages et plus ses dimensions mais
mais donne moi un petit peu son style de
jeu s'il te plaît au regard bas en
faisant le plus de recherches
statistiques sur john johnson j'ai
découvert qu'en plus d'être un des
multiples joe allen disponible cette
année l'étape qui est le huitième joueur
nommé du alan johnson oui oui ce parc la
cilicie ouais d'ailleurs il ya un
homonyme
deux homonymes qui en ce moment je joue
au tennis
ah oui foire est aussi je crois on dit
john johnson partout lui joué à duke
2006 7.19 qu'il ose vouloir absolument
il est de tous deux des trois joueurs
dont je parle aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être lui avec le profil athlétique
que le moins impressionnant c'est
pourquoi une mauvaise athlètes mais
c'est pour un athlète supérieur non plus
il faudrait pas vous fier aux matches
contre copine steyn 9 rebonds parce que
oui ils ont placé sous le panier comme
si c'était le deal là il tancé les
facteurs et les comptables
c'était peut-être c'était dégueulasse
raison que n'importe quoi il prenait des
one step life as we know it ce qu' il s'
amuser un peu dans le fond contre une
fact contre laquelle douch n'a même pas
la faille à jouer c'est lundi joueur qui
est le plus justement que son jeu est le
plus développé son excellent passeur
c'est un peu le coup de fil pour info
richie porte et alex sont pas
impossibles option que c'est d'ailleurs
un peu il n'y a plus le profil pour une
fois on parle mauvais shooter pas un bon
shooteur non plus sa mécanique est là
mais les raiders peur je trouve
il est reçu à trois points comme copine
state mais c'était la trajectoire du
ballon du ballon est très plate
défensivement parlant ça va je n'ai pas
encore vu défendre au périmètre dont
quatre ferme à prononcer là dessus mais
il va définir définitivement l'avenir à
poste cartes et non parce 3 moi j'aime
beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup les jeunes les joueurs
au juge sophistiqué et il ya beaucoup de
nuances au jeu de jason johnson
tout va dépendre si peu d'ici peu
développé en chine qui est fiable mais
en tout cas il est polyvalent et ça les
équipes nba ne croyons plus sûr moyen de
moi j'aime beaucoup beaucoup le profil
et chouchou s'il shoote beaucoup mais en
même temps il joue a dit oh que c'est
normal qu'ils sont tes chouchous un
autre challenge le dernier challenge
jours antoine c'est ton chouchou à toi
c'est celui de gonzaga giant size
gonzaga qui est alors à laquelle on
parle la meilleure équipe du pays
attention à baylor quand même
expérimenté mais on est là pour parler
du meneur de gonzaga meilleur combo à m
mais quel profil peux tu nous décrire
pour galles angels avant qu'on parle
mais français alors l'avantagé c'est que
je suis plus trop dans le monde du
basket donc je peux je peux dire encore
une fois que le coach ait maintien c'est
vraiment une grosse merde ne pas l'avoir
fait jouer un peu plus
je m'en fous je dis j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
non ce qui me frustre et c'est que ils
ont ils y mettaient beaucoup halliburton
on va dire à la mène alors que pour moi
ce que vous apportez beaucoup plus je
donc 5 ça on va dire que c'est un combo
guard
mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas un combo
guard c'est un meneur oui c'est juste un
grand meneur allemand oui oui c'est un
grand meneur rookie fait une taille
normale un problème bies pas non plus
l'immense qu'il appelle d'envergure et
lens ont leur nom il est pas
excessivement athlétique on l'a vu il
est quand même assez athlétique il est
pas il est pas non à petite île oui
c'est pas de gêne green s'est pas
qu'aider canning à moi c'est pas ça y
est relié à mme ça c'est clair mais par
quantic plus basse qu'à toi il est
vraiment sur les postes 1 et 2 il peut
il peut très bien décalé se mettre dans
le corner et puis shootant ce moteur ou
alors faire des courses faire des coeurs
il peut il peut très bien distribués et
de façon beaucoup plus fine on va dire
que cadet cunningham
il est capable de gérer le tempo d'un
match il est capable de
de de trouver la bonne personne avec de
bas ou de dribbles etc
il avait un excellent toucher sur son
shoot très bon shooteur et et puis voilà
et défensivement c'est pas mal c'est pas
c'est pas le défenseur du siècle mais
c'est pas mal on y manque de longueur
pour être vraiment excellent en défense
il a moins d'outils que green où aucun
dégât mais et de l'attitude de
l'attitude et la c c'est presque dommage
on va dire ce qui serait bien c'est
qu'il chute et draft parce que c'est le
genre de joueur qu'on a envie de voir
dans une équipe qui joue le titre quoi
je veux faire bien vie et son équipe
mais il faudra de bons joueurs à côté
qui sont capables de créer qui sont
capables de tout et il va voir ça cette
année à gonzaga ça va être assez
chouette de le voir de le voir fidh
notamment de route immigrés qui perd
tous qu'ils sont assez intelligents
c'est donc j'ai exactement et avec le
frenchy joël à yayi sur le bac courte de
cette équipe de gonzaga très belle
transition
je m'auto tape dans le dos pour parler
des français on vous parlera d'autre
prospère on n'a pas cité evans moblie
qui est aussi un candidat au top 10
scotty barron's terrance clark greg
brown joshuah christopher tout cela
qu'elle est blog de north carolina tout
cela on n'en parlera plus tard je les ai
aussi recensé dans un article que je
vais vous mettre à disposition sur le
site envergure penser aux poussées
freshman donc première année m6 des
volets ou joueurs de g-league à suivre
cette saison mais là on va parler des
français est pour le moment le français
le mieux classé parmi les les big board
et l'immeuble draft américaine c'est
johan begarin romain quel type de joueur
et begarin qu'est ce que les américains
lui trouve finalement
les américains lui trouve des qualités
j'imagine puisqu'ils ont projeté 12e
espionne à projeter 12e sur la sur sa
première à première ébauche de moc pour
la mois de juin bon c'est que je sais
que les mots qui sortent maintenant
elles sont toujours à prendre avec des
pincettes puisque cdu c'est de l'info
brute est souvent des des choses qui
sont qui sont faites alors que les
joueurs n'ont pas forcément été ou vu
depuis longtemps ou au moins vu
récemment encore plus ces temps ci
puisque dont les scouts nba n'ont
toujours pas le droit de voyager et
d'assister à des matchs voilà encore
plus compliqué aujourd'hui je prends
jouer wikio chez nous il ya quand même
assez peu de déplacements entre l'europe
et les états unis donc légalement pas
forcément été vu puisque sa jeune
begarin c1 c'est un poste 2 qui joue
actuellement au paris basket en pro b
qui fait qui fait un début de saison
plutôt plutôt plutôt solide par rapport
à l'an dernier je mets juste sur les
stats ce que j'ai pu en tête précisément
gerbe et ça tout à l'heure mais il fait
partie donc 2 du projet parisien
l'acquis qui comporte quelques quelques
joueurs quelques jeunes joueurs en
développement et qui sont encadrés par
par jcpraz donc c'est devenu un petit
peu le fond de commerce de développer
les joueurs et puis le fait il le fait
plutôt bien ce qu'il eut quelques
quelques personnes entre les mains comme
isaiah cordiner par le passé ou où il ya
koba ouattara qui est qu'ils sont tous
les deux en équipe de france aujourd'hui
donc on sait ça reste ça reste très
intéressant en termes de ventes et remet
de contexte pour eux donc à l'heure
actuelle et c'était un petit peu tronqué
entre les leaders scop et le championnat
aussi eu qu'un seul match de championnat
officiel de jouer pour paris alors
qu'ils ont joué la leader scapin entier
je suis trahi par le matériel n'était
pas c'est du direct
voilà je suis désolé c'est les aléas du
direct services publics ces deux
services publics souci maintenant voilà
c'est
sur cette année-là en leader ce que
parce que bon c'est la compétition et le
plus de matches en six matches il ya
actuellement 1 10 points 10 points de
moyenne trois bons et demi - pourcentage
de réussite à trois points qui a assez
effrayant mais sur un volume de tirs qui
a pas très élevé et puis bon sur encore
une fois sur une compétition il ya peu
de rythme l'interdît et autour de 33 %
avec un volume très faible
c'est un joueur qui est vraiment car à
volume athlétique et très agressif
beaucoup dans le drive qui qui dans un
contexte de championnat d'europe jeunes
où il a été évalué a été bien sûr
physiquement au dessus de la moyenne a
pratiquement on attend de voir un petit
peu l'évolution qui va pouvoir se noue
proposé sur sur l'année qui vient qui
est importante parce que on se rend
compte que ben c'était très dominant u16
et puis ça ça commence à plafonner un
petit peu les normales avec le niveau
qui augmente c'est automatique
souvent ça pour les prospects n'empêche
gros coffre
ah oui vraiment pour un arrière c'est
qu'il a une carrure antoine peut en
parler aussi sur laquelle on peut mettre
pas mal de muscles donc ça laisse les
américains aiment bien généralement ce
qu'on va observer chez lui sa capacité à
gérer le jeu avec ballon et puis a
ajouté romain d'ailleurs incapacité à
jouer à gérer de jeux avec ballon a
ajouté la capacité aussi en août à
pouvoir ressortir la balle de manière un
peu sur ce que l'heure actuelle son
ratio pas et s'ils veulent perdu un
petit peu comme un dernier quand même
papa génial cirque que sur la sur la
ligne droite sur du drive sur la vraie
percussions sur la première intention
des choses comme ça c'est un loir qui
est très intéressant mais il ya toute la
colique toute la construction apprendre
à désaxer le ballon se faire un peu plus
mal en défense parfois ce soit sur la
balle ou ou dans l'est ou dans les aides
ces choses là ça va être un petit peu
d'aidé des paramètres qui vont qui vont
jouer et qui vont bas soit impacté son
drap stock soit le soin le confirmer
soit au contraire le développer encore
une fois il dans un contexte qui lui
permet de bosser et donc cesser c'est
très intéressant
après de mémoire je me trompe peut-être
je suis pas sûre que
beaucoup de joueurs draftés en joue en
pro b mise à part la mise à part égale à
cordes signé à l'époque je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient une hormone de cartes des
jeunes joueur passé par la pro b qui ont
évolué en jeep et dit oui il y en a eu
mais directement la pro b je dis
peut-être une bêtise et où quelqu'un ou
pour le jeter des pierres avec grand
plaisir
mais il est mise à part les à décor
digne et je pense pas qu'il veuille et
l'autre exemple après c'est bon si on
lui souhaite bien entendu au moins le
même développement si c'était si c'était
mieux quand on voit ce que fait il est
aujourd'hui c'est très intéressant même
s'il n'est pas drafté 12e ce qui sera
pour voir probablement pas le cas on ne
va pas essayer de vous créer des
espérances tout de suite sauf saison
exceptionnelle de la part de joueurs nba
il sera pas racheté 12e parce que la
draft 2021 est très dense vers le haut
peut espérer un premier tour ça va on
voit l'idée c'est pas 2 soit ceux à ip
artificiellement soit dire que je
n'aurais pas bon c'est vraiment là on
n'est plus dans une dans une envie de
mise en perspective
parce que pour moi c'est très tôt et
puis encore une fois il peut s'en passer
c'est pas qu'elle ma saison va reprendre
un rythme un peu plus cohérent on sait
pas à quel moment les gens vont pouvoir
se déplacer on a vu l'aller les la draft
qui vient de se dérouler le procès
s'était complètement impacté et puis ça
c'est ça s'est joué à un petit peu dans
la dernière ligne droite sur les
dernières semaines voilà c'est c'est
très compliqué d'appréhender les choses
on espère pour lui un premier tour
effectivement avoir à voir mais en tout
cas c'est le prospect pour le moment le
mieux placé pour être drafté au premier
tour il ya d'autres candidats
un autre 2002 déjà romain mathieu
strazeele
'ainsi le début de saison est compliqué
pour lui moi le début de saison un peu
compliqué il ya été très exposé l'an
dernier assez rapidement dans un
contexte d'un petit peu différent
l'asvel que qu'il est cette année
cette année il ya un petit peu plus de
difficultés sur la route en début
d'année donc inévitablement banon dans
ces cas là c'est souvent les jeunes
joueurs qui qui entre guillemets
empathie ce sens que le terme empathie
soit péjoratif il ya des priorités quand
on doit gagner les matchs de
développement malheureusement ne peut
pas toujours en être une donc c c'est ce
qui explique que jusque-là matthew -
après ce sera un profil différent moi je
pense qu'on est on est clairement dans
un joueur qui qui qui peut avoir une
très belle carrière en europe
parce qu'il ya des choses il ya des
choses dans son développement qui
tendent vers ça mais c'est pareil est ce
que ça est-ce que ça peut pas glisser
sur un deuxième tour je pense que ce
sera peut-être l'objectif pour lui je
dirais je dirais dans les temps à venir
avoir avoir selon ce qui va se passer
cette année mais en tout cas pareil
c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà montré des
choses dans un registre totalement
différent de bégard post fait qu'ils ne
connaissent pas profit le post un
clairement même s'il n'est pas forcément
pas se faire c'est ça il est des plus
plus plus plus dans le scoring et dans
capable d'avoir une efficacité réelle
sur un temps court donc donc c'est ce
qui fait que l'an dernier il a eu il ya
eu dix minutes allaient moment où août
et au mali dont était en délicatesse
avec son épaule et parfois et parfois
donc encore pas totalement remis donc
c'est ce qui explique aussi qu'il est
plus qu il est plus exposé dans le
contexte de l'asvel où l'équipe a très
vite gagné des matches en euroligue dans
la renier dont ce qui lui a permis de
briller un petit peu bon un dernier
français pourquoi non on avait dit
qu'être un autre français mathieu un
cluedo milan d'un monde plus que les 2
dont on vient de parler
ouais il ya donc pas tout bonnement
gogo's un lycée qui est cette année au
ccrb la fin par de champagne basket qui
est prêté par le mans champagne basket
mais il y joue en compagnie de darna sve
lytica qui sera lui éligibles
automatique en tête l'an prochain je
crois un joueur lituanien gauzens et
c'est une espèce de dounia issa là qui
étaient étaient sur le stade du mans à
l'époque mans avait trouvé la
comparaison dit aaron fox jeu voire
assez assez filiforme montait fin très
rapide ligne droite ligne droite
pareil pas du tout pas du tout dans la
passe beaucoup beaucoup dans le scoring
il ya du travail sur le plan physique
parce qu'il faut inévitablement mettre
de la masse sur le sur le cadre sinon ça
je pense que ça peut ça peut quand même
difficilement passer à très très haut
niveau
et puis il ya un apprentissage à faire
au tour dans le fait de pouvoir faire
jouer que ces terres extrêmes il ya des
qualités offensives et de vitesse réelle
donc par ailleurs joueur un joueur à
suivre
est ce que c'est pour cette année ce que
c'est pour mon prochain moyens ça va
être un petit peu le jeu des agents
aussi qui vont qui vont déclarer tester
voir la toile alors j'en plante le décor
avec joueur qui pourrait égaler
évidemment n'est pas au courant encore
des des enjeux de dans sept mois
la draft ce serait dans 7 mois voire les
mois et l'asie va mal comme 15 avril
on pourrait en parler pour le terroir
occasions mais ils jouent pour le méga
l'ex l'espèce de fermat prospects mais
par contre si un jour on n'a pas parlé
c'est ismaël kamagaté aussi on avait
tellement ri di cu mentionnerait donc
lui sur dans un registre de poste 5 qui
jouaient en championnat régional n'y a
pas si longtemps que ça a gravi les
échelons très vite même chose lui je
vois il joue à paris en pro b à un vrai
poste 5 avec énormément de travail
devant lui encore mais une avancée très
intéressante sur le plan physique sur la
coordination c'est ces derniers temps
donc pareil quelque chose dans un
registre de deux joueurs de très grande
taille ça peut ça peut être quelqu'un de
quelqu'un d'intéressant l'appareil 13
points de moyenne sur les six matches
qu'il a joués en leader scup cette année
avec 8 rebonds 4 rebonds offre donc
c'est il ya encore plein de choses c'est
perfectible ça manque encore de vitesse
a manqué un manque encore de dureté par
moments mais il ya un profil après c'est
pareil c'est du joueur intérieur est ce
qu il a intérêt à y aller cette année ce
qui est il faut pas attendre un an de
plus à voir mais bon voilà c'est
toujours dans le projet parisien c'est
un autre axe de développement fort pour
l'équipe il ya souvent des coups à jouer
au second tour pour les pivots
internationaux ouais et en l'occurrence
avec cette classe d'âge en regardant le
tableau général
sans vraiment encore trop connaître j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya assez peu de
postes cinq pur qui seront candidats
donc il peut aussi bénéficier de profil
un peu décalé original
oui ça pleure ça peut être ça aussi
antoine est ce que tu as quelque chose à
ajouter sur un des français les a vus
jouer tous presque tous vous avez vu
huit tous non pas pour expliquer
pourquoi joignait aussi où je pense que
du boni est resté sur les impressions du
16 ou de mémoire je dis ça à la chambre
on avait shooté à 41% à 3 points wii
sachant que pour un européen il a
tendance à finir largement au-dessus du
cercle ce qui fait toujours plaisir
on sait très bien donc ajoutait cela les
45% en trois points c'était vraiment
hyper c'était fantastique
on l'avait on l'avait tous on se disait
ça sera sera piquemal un problème c'est
que le shoot arrive enfin pas régresser
6 était voilà
et oui les pistes --un l'histoire d'une
compétition il faut qui stabilisent ça
ou alors qui stabilise le land de l'est
la distribution au choix sinon ça sera
plus compliqué il était assez monstrueux
aussi défensivement il avait
complètement étouffé rocco rk singh qui
est nôtre notre prospère numéro en
préférer niveau des internationaux on
vous en parlera de reproches en podcast
des internationaux père cas c'est une
gare au babc rajhi et consorts en
sachant que leur casting il a le
physique de kharouba maintenant ouais
c'est ça il est plus l'ailier longiligne
qu'on aimait tant messieurs nous sommes
nous avons nous avons un peu débordé du
timing
c'était attendu puisque on vous a
présenté le tableau global concernant
les candidats offert ce pic et
les français pour cette pour la drave
2021 le programme pour cette saison 4
d'envergure ça va être dans chaque
podcast désormais celui ci fait ce
faisant exception
un seul scouting report sur un seul
joueur
et on va vous publiez ça de manière
régulière
probablement le mercredi midi c'est
encore en discussion mais probablement
tous les mercredis midi
un peu comme à l'époque il y avait le
basket nba sur canal le mercredi après
midi
eh bien ce sera le podcast d'envergure
pour votre votre fin de semaine
[Musique]
ça sera la saison 4 et ça sera à suivre
avec bénac romain avec antoine avec alan
avec manu avec nico et avec toute la
data team qui va également être mis à
contribution pour tous nos report
rendez vous sur envergure point ces eaux
et pour les podcasts évidemment vous
abonner sur votre plateforme d'écouté
vous nous mettez une bonne note
s'il vous plaît si vous avez bien aimé
la le retour notamment le come-back
d'antoine toujours est ce qu'il ya un
nouveau parfum de saucisson a servi à me
prostituer un peu un peu mais je suis le
pink le plus classe 2 devant permettre
non c'est sûr ce sont nature ce soir
c'est nature on revient aux basiques
c'était perdure épisode 1 saison 4 merci
beaucoup les gars car c'est à toi alex
merci et puis à bientôt à bien que tout
le monde